[Applause]
it's become a symbol of resistance
raising three fingers to the sky a
creative way to defy authorities in a
country with stringent restrictions on
freedom of expression
protests have been growing in bangkok
since mid-july following a number of
political scandals
including the forced disbanding of the
main opposition party
the leedless protest movement has two
main demands
a shake-up of thailand's
military-dominated government and
reforms to the role of the powerful
royal family
if we had a good government a democratic
government
our politics our education and our
health care system would be better than
this
this is our dream and we hope that our
dream will come true
demonstrators want to see the
resignation of this man prime minister
prayu chanocha
he's a military man who came to power in
2014 during a coup
then tightening his power in disputed
elections this year
i cannot accept a system that is corrupt
but with the last few rallies there was
no response from those who hold power
the three core demands were ignored and
even the most basic demand to stop
harassing people
the government didn't listen to us
the prime minister has slammed the
protests as irresponsible
saying they are putting many ties at
risk during the coronavirus pandemic
any major flare-up of infections will
lead to terrible consequences
and even worse economic destruction the
likes of which we have never seen
the pro-democracy movement is also
calling for royal family reform
criticizing the wealthy royal house is
taboo in thailand
and can lead to hefty penalties and jail
time
protesters want to see more transparency
when it comes to royal affairs
the protest has vowed to last all
weekend with demonstrations continuing
throughout the night
for more let's bring in our
correspondent florian nush
who is following the story for us in
bangkok florian it's dark now as we can
see uh
our protesters still out
absolutely and that does not come as a
surprise
because the organizers had made it clear
from the beginning
that they would hold a rally that would
not only
um you know be bigger in terms of
participants but also
bigger in terms of duration so
the main speakers are about to get on
stage as we speak now so around nine
o'clock local time here in bangkok
we have heard some pretty spicy stuff or
i should say
dicey stuff already but as i said the
main acts are still to come
and we'll have to wait and see how these
protests
will unfold even further
these people were warned not to protest
what's been the police response so far
the police have actually remained
quite lenient as they have been all
through those last
weeks they might have realized that
if they were to crack down on those
people on those protesters they might
have an even bigger problem
at hand because there are just so many
people organizers are saying that we
actually have
reached a hundred and thousand
protesters um
by now and um so in order to disperse
such a crowd
this would need massive force and the
police have decided not to use that
massive force
now at the same time they have said that
um
the students have to obey the rules
there has not been any violence yet
but as i said the main speeches are
still to come and those main speeches
will deal with the monarchy
and by thai law criticizing the monarchy
can land you in jail so we'll have to
see
if the police will stay lenient as they
have been so far
okay florian nusch in bangkok thank you
for that update
you